apparently there's some playstation
event going on right now and they
dropped this marvel spider-man morales
ps5
gameplay demo as a fan of the spider-man
ps4
game i cannot wait to check this out i
thought the teaser trailer for this was
awesome so let's see what's in store
today
i love those pages
it's too cold to change out here
dang i'm late for mom's rally
subway car check you got the house key
yeah i got it
come on we're gonna be late
hey dude i am so filling your suit with
snow
are you still wearing your suit yeah you
know just in case
it's gonna be fun
oh no see this is my favorite part of
living in harlem
pop-up street fair best food in the city
awesome music
yeah this would be great for the last
three hours
what do you think about rio morales are
you going to vote for her
she's been a teacher my whole life have
similar skill sets right
educating them making sure they don't
grow things at each other
hi i'm brian horton creative director at
instagram games hey buddy we're excited
to show you this first look at gameplay
from marvel spider-man miles morales our
story picks up
one year after the events of the first
game okay and we find miles new home
harlem is in danger trouble bruised
while mile's mom
rio morales leads an election rally okay
between the devious energy corporation
roxanne
and the underground a high-tech criminal
army led by the tinkerer
starts to break out no way on
playstation 5 hardware
the underground attacks rockstar sending
the rally into chaos
spills onto the brake lane bridge where
the underground tries to steal roxanne's
experimental energy source
new form let's take a look
[Music]
let's not shoot each other all right
[Applause]
ignore everything else
owie
[Music]
here we go
oh
i cannot wait to play this i cannot wait
[Music]
how many combo nice
whoa those camera angles
ah
wow
oh that's great that's great
come on bus driver
oh my
oh
[Music]
there it is there it is
square
oh
[Music]
well done greater well done
that was beautiful absolutely beautiful
i love how this this whole thing was
brought together because they did it in
a way where
they didn't really reveal much of the
plot
you think they're setting you up because
they say it takes place one year after
the last game if you haven't played that
yet please do yourself a favor
play that video game all right they're
gonna confirm some theories that we had
about like the possibility of peter
parker being dead
uh information such as that i imagine
that's probably the case right now
either way what we got
here you know you obviously get to show
off a little bit more of what makes
miles morales spider-man different than
peter parker spider-man a lot of
video games usually have to upgrade your
combos and such and
moves and maneuvers as you keep playing
the game you start earning points and
whatnot or
you know collecting items to upgrade and
it seems like here very early on that
you're equipped with a lot of different
combinations
very early on one thing that i love that
the spider-man game does um
is they're so seamless with
transitioning through these cinematics
and especially during the action
sequences these fight scenes
where you have to you know you have to
like really rapidly press a button or
something like that
in the middle of a cinematic that's
going on those are always very exciting
and make the game feel
that much more cinematic and visceral
and it feels like it's happening
here i'm trying to like search online
the voice sounds like yuri
of the vil i'm not that familiar with uh
tinkerer is the name of this villain
i'm not that familiar with that
character the voice sounded like the
voice of yuri
i could be wrong about that be curious
to know what your guys's thoughts are on
it and the other thing too
that i noticed was when the graphics
came up at the end
said ps4 so i'm wondering if this is
also
going to be available for ps4 it must be
if they're
including the old logos yeah i mean you
know i mean ps4 has probably still got a
little bit more legs left on it before
they
full-on transition out of making games
for it entirely so it'll probably yeah
just be a little less
nice looking than it will on ps5 but
yeah this was like a super enthralling
trailer and it's funny because it
reminded
me or a demo i should say it reminded me
of the avengers one just because like
the big action
set piece takes place on a bridge and
yet for some reason this one
pulled me in that much more and it felt
even more like you're really
in the shoes of the hero and i thought
that was one of the coolest parts of
this just the
scope in general of being in miles
morales shoes
watching as like parts of the bridge
fall out and having that i mean i'm sure
that you know this is incorporated in
other superhero games too but i liked
how they also focused on it's not just
about
fighting the bad guys but it's also
about you know rescuing people and you
know
maneuvering around falling debris and
stuff like that and so yeah just little
taste of like the
worlds that we'll get to see like the
harlem sequence i thought was really
beautiful that
little uh piece of dialogue that clues
you into his mom running for office and
that being part of the story yeah this
just looked like a really nice blend of
a spider-man movie with a spider-man
video game oh yeah i mean right when
they came to the connecting bridge part
it was just so apparent that he was
going to be doing that at some point
which reminds you the fairy scene from
homecoming or makes you
meme like this is it was the fairy scene
from homecoming and making me flashback
to even
uh the spider-man 1 sequence in a way
having that here
was just so grandiose
in every sense imaginable i only played
the ps4 version of spider-man a few
months ago it's only been a few months
but the graphics certainly do look
sharper than the previous game
and this is only a demo of what we're at
right now
and uh obviously you can see when he
goes into camouflage mode there's a life
span
on the camouflage as well otherwise this
game would be way too easy
to just camouflage your way through
every fight because i like how in the
middle of the fight you can camouflage
yourself
yeah they're like where'd he go yeah
there's so much here to look forward to
and
i don't recall the ps4 one going to
manhattan i mean it's pretty
vast over how much you can explore of
new york city in the other one
uh i don't recall them going to heart i
know you play as miles morales
briefly obviously not a spider-man in
that game yeah i don't recall being
spider-man
in harlem saving the people there got
some white
savior that's what they should have done
yeah that should be peter parker in
harlem that's what they should have
flipped it too
they're only teasing the tinker here but
you know the last game had a wide
plethora of villains
and the first trailer for this game
showcased
more than one villain i don't know
exactly what they're going to be
building
up to imagine like the way how they had
mr sinister as
the main villain essentially but then it
was kind of like also doc ock you know
who they were maneuvering around in
terms of villains so maybe it starts off
with tinker is the main villain but then
maybe there's a
even bigger baddie on the horizon that
miles morales has to take down we'll see
guys we'll see right now everything
we're getting i can imagine this being
game of the year
they also got god of war the ragnarok
game that
they just did a showcase for as well so
funniest god of war yet let's see what
we can do
guys so what did you think about this
trailer subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell last but
not least
i would like to shout out today a man
named scuba steve
scuba it's been a while since i've heard
from you dude but halloween season is
approaching right now
i know you're a huge fan of horror so
i'm really hoping i could hear back from
you as soon as possible to see
what the hell it is you're catching up
on recommender stuff
and also knowing you know what your love
life is like i know we constantly used
to talk about that in your dating life
and then honestly with horror movie
season coming around
people wanting to kind of just netflix
and chill quarantine up together
now could be your time to hook some
ladies
in candyman style kill them yes
murder them in your home and then
graffiti them with your spray painting
abilities
make them say your name a lot in the
mirror until they are just like
full on all they can think about is
scuba steve before they die
that's how i want to go just looking at
you let's not make this about you john
that's how
everyone should be lucky enough to go is
at the hands
of scoob steve take care scuba
[Music]
you